[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission ça décolle et
ensemble vous allez parler alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
être la même alors au samedi dans la
commune du Tampon plus précisément au
niveau du python texto 2000 150 mètres
d'altitude et nous où ça nous ça va nous
ça va ici python de l'eau trois temps
alors le pito Texas si nous regarde bien
pour reconnaître ça nous aussi
en tout cas on dirait un a brouilla
arrive banana en pause bonjour bonjour
Comment allez
-vous
et
en mode randonnée mais quelques heures
comme ça
on est monté on est monté à ce petit
pyto là le piton debout et là maintenant
on va vers la gamma c'est après on va
retourner à nez de bœuf d'accord et
comment ça se faisait de nombreux comme
ça là là tous les vendredis on fait une
rando comme ça partout dans l'île et
beaucoup sur le même massif du de la
Fournaise et que ça donne quand tu fais
de la randonnée comme ça mais elle est
beaux paysages
et la convivialité oxygène
et en parlant de mon covidia comme ça à
cause de tu fais une randonnée comme ça
tous les ventres dit est-ce que ça il
fait chacun des petits repas et là c'est
même un petit goûter simple
on partage
des gâteaux on mange les gâteaux
au chocolat
ok mais en tout cas j'en ai un réseau
profite bien on a trouvé
alors du coup là m'y arrive mais on a
une piste là le sentier loin
bonjour bonjour bonjour
comment il est bonjour ça va bonjour les
filles ça va bien alors ça va bien
bonjour alors bonjour monsieur ça va
salut
c'est une super balade facile on est
venu avec des enfants de Saint-Denis
exactement mais comment ça se fait ça en
philosophe ben on a la chance ici en
haut le dépassement et l'OMF on calibré
des pistes spécialement pour le VTT et
celle-là la piste piton de l'eau c'est
une piste agréable familiale c'est pour
ça que on vient prendre le bon air ici
en haut les vrais calibrer que ça veut
dire ça c'est une station VTT des pistes
ont été classées un peu comme les pistes
de ski les pistes vertes des rouges des
Noirs etc
celle-là c'est une verte c'est une verte
c'est une bleue donc elle est facile
elle est agréable et voilà d'accord et
ça c'est alors c'est des vélos
commencent à électrique c'est bon vélo
commence à un petit peu tout électrique
mais encore jeune encore costaud
d'accord donc voilà OK
et la sensation qu'on fait vélo parce
que là
il y a des années dans le bonnet
[Rires]
du centre Saint-Denis nous les exprès
dans le bonheur une météo magnifique et
en bas la balle point de vue le
magnifique hein on a de jolis affaires
pour voir ouais ouais
il vaut la peine de tout là la pluie et
tomber un petit peu là là
bien remplie pas de problème
ça va sur le chantier par ici en tout
cas parce que moi après vélo bonne
continuation à ça merci
[Musique]
on retrouve mon moment rien que la même
mot qui a des dents derrière Elena la
montagne soleil
comme si la nature déconné ah la la
paradis pour nous
alors du coup noir arrive à peu près à
mi-chemin Sénégal c'est que nous change
vraiment de paysages et là si le garde
bien que ça doit la piste VTT donc
depuis
longtemps ici ici ici on a le branche
vers ici
et puis aussi une croise une petite
tamarin des hauts et ben nous nous a
continué sur le sentier jusqu'au piton
de l'eau allez allons-nous
alors ben voilà là moi la quitte le
sentier et mes retours à moi sur une
piste alors ça nous les exactement et
ben là nous les à la ravine du petit
Saint-Pierre à 2075 mètres d'altitude il
reste à nous encore une heure avant pour
nous arriver plutôt de l'eau et nous on
voit bien que sur la piste il y en a
nous les retrouve nougat carré à cheval
ou sinon à vélo
bonjour les gars bonjour Comment allez
ça va bien salut ça va oui ça va bien
souvent la réunion nous fait le tour
vite fait est-ce que les est-ce que les
olives
[Rires]
à découvrir juste le paysage change à
chaque commune ces différents
mètres d'altitude et il faut savoir que
c'est le seul lac volcanique de l'île en
tout cas il est vraiment magnifique
grâce à le reflet du soleil sur les
vraiment impressionnant
vraiment la vue ça nous vient à pied
sinon en vélo ok la Réunion on a gagné
et pour ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode 2 l'émission de la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]